Alright, here goes. There are three inherited methods, set text, set answer,
and check answer. And you can tell because they are over here, and they're not
over here. Because choice question extends question, it picks up all of those
methods automatically. It inherits them. Display, on the other hand, is both
here and here. Which tells us that the choice question was not happy with this
display and provides its own. It overrides the one from the super class.
Finally, there's add choice, which wasn't over here at all, so that's an added
method that only appears in choice question, but not in question. Next, you'll
get to implement these two methods, but the good part is, you don't have to
implement these because they are already in the question class and choice
question just inherits them.